[Musik]
warum stellt denn nicht die ganze Welt
Olivenöl aus der frühernte her wenn man
das ganze vergleicht kann man auch 7 bis
9 Kilo grüner unreifer Oliven etwa 1
Liter reines Olivenöl aus der Früh Ernte
herstellen vergleicht man das jetzt mit
Reifen Oliven die wirklich bis Februar
oder März Reifen durften dann braucht
man etwa nur drei Kilo um 1 Liter
Olivenöl herzustellen und so hat man bei
der Früh Ernte wirklich nur ein Drittel
des Ernteertrages und es geht natürlich
auch auf die Kosten also man könnte auch
wenn man wollte konventionelles Olivenöl
was ist im Supermarkt gibt gar nicht in
der Früh Ernte machen weil es gar nicht
so viele Olivenbäume auf der ganzen Welt
gibt und weil die Industrie natürlich
immer ganz viel Geld machen möchte und
irgendwo auch machen muss strecken Sie
Ihr Olivenöl lassen die Oliven ganz reif
werden und das ist eben das was das
Olivenöl später eben nicht mehr so ganz
gesund macht wir haben gesagt wir
konzentrieren uns auf die frühernte
wollen das beste Olivenöl der Welt
herstellen
[Musik]